foreign
[Music]
we are back this week with the latest
news from the world of movies and series
included are two pieces of news about
different Spider-Man projects the sequel
to an action film series with Vin Diesel
a first image of Lady Gaga as Harley
Quinn and a new cast member for Deadpool
3. we also talk about an I Am Legend
sequel with Will Smith and Michael B
Jordan and reveal why the upcoming How
to Train Your Dragon remake is very
different from the previous films have
fun watching
many are already eagerly awaiting the
upcoming Deadpool 3. a number of
newcomers have joined the film series
featuring The somewhat unusual Marvel
hero most notably Wolverine star Hugh
Jackman the 54 year old Australian is
currently doing extensive workouts to
prepare for the role as Wolverine as
Jackman impressively demonstrated on
social media a couple of days ago the
training seems to be paying off so far a
small dig at his colleague Ryan Reynolds
was not to be missed after all he is a
mere eight years younger and thus no
match for Jackman it was only a few days
later that it was announced who exactly
Reynolds and Jackman have to get into
shape for deadline recently revealed the
signing of the antagonist of the two
lead characters it is Emma Corin who was
already impressive as lady die in
Netflix's the crown she is supposed to
follow in the footsteps of the superior
villain cable this is not so simple
after all the villain was not only
popular with the audience but also gave
the almost Immortal Deadpool a hard time
unfortunately it is not revealed yet
which character corn will take over
exactly however the team around director
Sean Levy and lead actor Ryan Reynolds
will surely find a suitable candidate
from the Marvel Universe for Corin
herself Deadpool 3 could be the final
leap into the Realms of the big
Hollywood movies if she is able to
convince the audience adequately if
current rumors are to be believed the
crown star could assume the role of the
Sorceress spiral who was originally
captured by Mojo already hinted at in
Deadpool 2 and later banished to Earth
by the ruler of Mojo world in the
original Comics she later becomes part
of the X-Force and would even stand
alongside her former adversary Deadpool
it is worth noting however that this is
pure speculation so far we are looking
forward to more news Deadpool 3 is
scheduled for release on November 8
2024.
the HBO series The Last of Us has become
one of the most popular series in recent
years those responsible also owe this to
the creators of the video games because
the duo of Neil druckman and Bruce
Straley was inspired by a very specific
film during the creation process of the
first game we are talking about the
post-apocalyptic drama I Am Legend with
Will Smith who plays A Gifted scientist
as well as one of the last surviving
humans accompanied by his dog Sam he
conducts research in the devastated
Urban Canyons of New York City to find a
cure for the altered measles virus that
has almost entirely turned Humanity into
zombie-like infected people the movie
was mostly well received upon its
release in 2008 but to this day many
fans are bothered by the ending of the
movie which results in the depth of the
main character in an alternate ending it
was opted to have Dr Robert Neville
survive instead and make his way to
Vermont with Anna and Ethan nevertheless
this version is a lot darker as Neville
realizes that the infected have their
own social structures and thus will
sooner or later overrun the few
uninfected people as screenwriter Akiba
goldsman now reports a sequel is
currently being worked on that focuses
more on the book by Richard Matheson as
a result the ending of the original film
will be disregarded and the survival of
Robert Neville will be considered as
Canon instead likewise he revealed that
several decades will have passed between
part 1 and part two so the protagonist
will be significantly older this also
fits with the signing of MCU star
Michael B Jordan who joins the cast as a
newcomer and is rumored to play the son
of the lead character Robert Neville
sadly there is no release date for I am
Legend 2 yet but we'll be sure to keep
you posted
Joker from 2019 is the most successful
R-rated film of all time the film which
is separate from the dceu and thus
stands on its own has grossed a total of
more than 1 billion US Dollars and thus
almost 300 million dollars more than the
runner-up Deadpool 2. expectations for
the sequel are correspondingly high but
so far there is still no first trailer
or teaser instead a first image from the
film has already been published showing
main character Arthur Flack getting a
shave director Todd Phillips has now
followed up with a second image in which
Lady Gaga can now be spotted in her new
role for the first time fittingly for
Valentine's Day last Tuesday the two
characters are looking deep into each
other's eyes a more detailed look at
Harley Quinn's outfit is unfortunately
not available yet which is why it is not
easy to tell exactly how well the A Star
is Born actress is doing in her role
since the story of Joker Folia do is
supposed to include some music physical
parts it's fortunate that Lady Gaga
already has valuable experience in this
area the sequel is presumably about
Arthur Fleck getting to know Dr harleen
quinzel a psychiatrist who is in charge
of the patient later she falls madly in
love with the joker and thus becomes
delusional herself hence the title Folia
do which translates as Madness by two
she then also appears under her more
familiar name Harley Quinn how much the
movie will Implement from the comic
original however is still unclear Joker
2 Foley Adu will run in cinemas from
October 4th 2024.
after Spider-Man no way home and its
Multiverse Adventure at the end of 2021
resulted in a huge hit for the MCU the
movie series starring Tom Holland is far
from over rumor has it that three more
movies featuring the MCU Spider-Man will
be released and now there is some early
information about the upcoming
Spider-Man 4. this was officially
announced by Marvel CEO Kevin feige in
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
those responsible already have a story
and Big Ideas in mind for Spider-Man 4.
currently the script is also being
written meaning that a potential start
of filming before the end of this year
is entirely possible the film's plot is
said to be strongly linked to the
upcoming series Daredevil Born Again
Daredevil actor Charlie Cox was already
seen in a brief appearance in Spider-Man
no way home it is also suspected that
the upcoming movies with Tom Holland
will focus Less on other MCU Heroes who
stand by the sometimes awkward Peter
Parker instead the emphasis might be
placed on other characters from the
gigantic Spider-Man universe similar to
what is already the case with the
forthcoming Spider-Man across the
spider-verse it would also be beneficial
for the character development of the
main character not to have to rely on
the likes of Dr Strange all the time so
far there is no release date for
Spider-Man 4 but we will keep you posted
we have known about the upcoming Amazon
series silk spider Society since early
2021 which is the result of a
collaboration between Sony and the
streaming provider as we found out at
the end of last week Amazon will not
leave it at one series and has now
secured the rights to Spider-Man Noir
unlike silk spider Society the new
project is to be released in a live
action format and will realistically
present New York in the 1930s this
cooperation is only feasible because
Sony still owns the movie rights for the
Spider-Man universe making it possible
to make movies and series about the
friendly neighborhood spider outside of
Disney plus Spider-Man Noir already made
a debut appearance in Spider-Man into
the spider-verse in which he played a
part alongside numerous other versions
of the superhero in the original the
Spider-Man Noir was voiced by none other
than Nicholas Cage which is why there is
currently some speculation that cage
might actually take the lead role in the
LA live action series the rumors are
also fueled by an interview conducted in
early January cage expressed great
interest in the character to Screen Rant
even though he will not be returning for
the animated sequel Spider-Man across
the spider-verse despite being set in
the 1930s Spider-Man Noir is a
comparatively modern phenomenon as the
comic book series was published in 2009
the screenplay for Spider-Man Noir was
written by Mortal Kombat author Oren
uzio while Phil Lord Chris Miller and ex
Sony boss Amy Pascal are responsible for
the production a release date has not
been set yet but we will keep you up to
date
Hollywood star Vin Diesel has been known
for many years above all for his
involvement in the popular Fast and
Furious franchise he first played the
character of Dom Toretto in 2001 and now
over two decades later he is starring in
the last two installments of Fast and
Furious 10 and 11 bringing the film
series to a close what is often
overlooked in the process is that even
before the first part diesel was already
starring in another now also well-known
movie series namely pitch black the
first of three installments was released
in 2000 and laid the groundwork for The
Chronicles of Riddick for many years now
people have been waiting for a fourth
part of the brutal science fiction film
series around the anti-hero Richard B
Riddick then just a few days ago to the
joy of many fans the fourth installment
was officially announced with the title
Riddick Furia according to the official
synopsis the lead character is supposed
to return to his home World although he
no longer has has any memories of it on
site he meets other furians whose
existence is threatened by a new Mutual
enemy Riddick also discovers that he
probably has more in common with these
furians than he initially thinks besides
Vin Diesel who has been regularly
promoting a Riddick 4 for some time now
director and screenwriter David Tui is
also coming back to direct as he did for
the previous installments the 67 year
olds announced goal is to explore the
origins of the protagonist in more
detail whether Diesel and Tui will
succeed in attracting audiences back to
the cinema more than 10 years after the
rather average third part remains to be
seen a release date has not been seen as
of yet
nobody probably expected this at the
moment there will be a new How to Train
Your Dragon movie in just about two
years time in contrast to the popular
animated franchise however there will be
a decisive change the movie will be shot
entirely in live action format and thus
diverges from the previous three
features it was announced that Dean
deblois will be devoting himself to the
project as director and screenwriter the
52 year old has directed every How to
Train Your Dragon installment so far
making him the right choice for fans of
the franchise still it should be noted
that dib lua's last live-action movie
was quite some time ago
16 years to be exact and that was a
documentary about the band Seeger Rose
in terms of story the upcoming film is
supposed to be a remake the animated
film series continues to stand on its
own and is not directly related to it
although the protagonist hiccup will
certainly be the main focus again
whether those responsible will be
successful with their live-action film
is something we'll be able to find out
in barely two years How to Train Your
Dragon is scheduled to hit theaters on
March 14 2025.
if you want to know more about future
projects from Hollywood you should check
out our compilation of all the Super
Bowl 2023 trailers included are trailers
for some of the best upcoming movies
such as Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
fast X Indiana Jones 5 the dial of
Destiny and many many more thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
thank you